oh Jesus Oh Jason's Jack what's wrong
with you I don't know this video will
begin after a word from our sponsor Nord
VPN epic what you're surfing the
internet unprotected check out Nord VPN
they have thousands of servers in over
61 countries no to data logging
military-grade encryption your darkest
secrets are safe with Nord VPN ever
since Nord VPN sponsored me I've been
using it every single day it is a
fantastic product I definitely recommend
that you guys should check it out it's
also add for Android and iOS so you can
even use it on your phone obviously but
why Lord be at the end well it's the
only VPN that has a perfect score on PC
Magazine epic it has Nord in the title
epic
remember we're know all those hackers
were hacking printers and PewDiePie
whatever not epic for printers this
stuff wouldn't happen if you just had a
VPN noobs it's a great product and it
protects you online so check it out and
if you go to north VPN calm /pd pie you
get 70% off a three-year deal and that's
a great price enter the code PewDiePie
and get an additional month free epic
thanks for to be banned for sponsoring
this video let's get on with it
guys loading hey are you my who are you
are you there Jack no I'm gonna see you
yet I'm joining I'm loading in thank you
say yeah I mean I think jack which
seater you want on the plane oh wait
look over here oh god I think I'm behind
you where am I I'm in a different seat
about the right hand side or you're in
business class
oh yeah no I can't afford business god I
am like oh god okay instead I see you
lying on the ground but I'm standing
above my character Who am I yeah I'm
behind you okay wait Here I am
okay I'm in
I'm glad you came her hey you later
Oh shake hand oh sorry that's book right
she can hello oh yeah what's up my gamer
how did you get X tick huh chip shop I
heard oh oh what's wrong with you I'm
Jam all over my screen no I shop shop
for real you're shocked this is
minecraft graphic looks so good chip
shop shop shop okay watch this chop shop
man okay shop shop Oh God what's killing
me did you hit me you hit me
screw you environment oh oh you killed
me oh god they survived zero ah this is
so sad
chip shop tonight I might just dead
forever then oh I gotta work I got the
log don't worry gamer wait where's my ex
wow you're so strong how do you do I
don't know
[Music]
smokin okay I don't remember how you
play this I don't think we're going to
play this seriously I chopped other tree
oh you like this minecraft
yeah how about this notch but you can't
do this in Minecraft wait can you chop
super fast
[Laughter]
right on your butt ball that frickin
nerd these Smurfs come here come here
your head okay okay
Oh beat that be there you go you're
stinky brain okay hey don't ever oh you
just annihilated that [ __ ] okay yes
here you want my log right let me get it
hey we should turn the forest into
DeForest shirts over there can you save
me yeah I'll see me don't hit me how do
you save me can I accept the guy okay
I'm back hello Hey okay I find my stuff
hello okay okay okay so I found how to
make basic fire how did you get your
video oh okay we need two more sticks to
make basic fire and well two more stick
okay
yeah save this strength get to strength
of log okay
how do I survive how do I not die
anymore oh look I have photo of child
oh let's photo look at thank you whoa
whoa Jesus Christ hope to believe how
you do up arrow
oh oh oh gee crunchy how do you care
cheek Reggie quicky quicky okay I want I
want acts again because it makes me feel
like big guy
mmm I can spring key spring key ha hey
my gamer no wait
how are you so fast just you have to put
your hands like straight so you run
faster through the wind it doesn't work
whole left click in Oh God
Oh bunny kill it kill it kill the bunny
[ __ ] oh there is too fast they have
figured it out baby let's kill Bambi
wait sneaky sneaky
don't don't make a sell
don't make it any smell okay wait wait
wait I got it
did you okay epic okay so now we saw
Jason's Jack what's wrong with you
I don't know
there's people here they just ride away
up into the trees
I don't like cowards they must be French
a bit hey you wanna kiss it's a strong
nice leg very good finally I have leg oh
thank god
this is officer let's find the left leg
so I can walk
ok we need to chop chop chop chop let's
go we're bad guy go
are they right over here cowards
hey I don't know where they went there's
a bus ours hello ride run again
hold left click left clicking click in
your lipstick as you're moving forward
Oh full leg
I'll run fast so I get them oh god I
don't know I don't know ok wait let me
get we're gamers whoa careful jack
careful I don't want you to die ok I try
kill squirrel but no work ok
all right we got an assault them why we
killed you stinky clothes Oh coward
coward where'd he go he's run yeah yeah
hey chop off his legs jump assume oh you
can kill me sorry
again I don't think about
look Wow
oh you change your clothes kill the bird
as you go slag away whatever it's okay
I find leg again I got night papa
morning okay it's getting dark so we
should probably set up a camp I guess so
can you shut down tree with leg okay I
think my character might be dying oh you
can look at your watch to see oh I'm
starving uh hungry hungry oh my actual
watch is telling me what's happening
yeah okay you know don't get burned by
it and now we cook yeah yeah delicious
oh there you go there I'm cooking meat
oh yes fire take it take it take it take
it take it take it take it let go let go
Oh taste good how it tastes almost kill
me hold your middle finger goodness oh
oh oh God
stop it blow it work it worked thanks
gamer
I've strong lungs
hey no problem okay we need to build bed
leave-leave unsticky here you want you
want suitcase
hello me yeah here I buy for you say a
lot of friend hey hey hey hey Madhu hey
Madhu Jack I think I'm
Oh God Oh God Oh you can make friends
with him hey oh I'm a lizard plate I'm a
lizard
[Applause]
oh I'm a lizard beyblade okay okay
build shelter damn you're good at that
I'm so good gamer you're good at that
kiss him
okay we need one I'll put them in your
bed okay thank you
oh no I broke the show I don't know god
damn it I tried so hard okay my deals
okay I'll go and find my this is fine
you can save and then wait to win you
we're sleeping sleep did you break this
oh we can only use it twice and then it
destroys tonight oh [ __ ] ocean blasting
mrs. stinky
Oh God Wow Wow bye
how's that working out for you pop pop
okay okay are you ready to watch me flip
hop up ready hop up are you watching do
the flip through the flesh oh whoa
there's a log here you got it you got to
do this go faster
that's how you swim I forgot okay yeah
super fast swimming maybe oh look at us
intrepid explorers okay Cheyenne tree
that's so cool
its aggressive let's go oh all right
okay
swimming class trim so fast Wow whoa
there you're actually really fast
yes I'm doing the motion us I'm doing
the motion of the ocean
and our boat boat I think but oh so mean
we can play shark oh god I hope not
he's out do the dishes Oh fishes do the
dishes but they don't like the [ __ ]
Oh shark shark shark oh no oh God
either that or I'm paralyzed and that I
think he picked you
now he in that might intestine that's
fine okay I made it I made it
hey who is this fish you and this is me
oh god what the hell is this
you got some mood lighting I'm good
again I don't know who you were talking
to before but look at this yeah jerks
that Sharkey's who killed them and why I
did because they killed my boy so I
killed their entire family where was he
the best boy oh look I was you yeah oh
I'm told you were the best boy what do
you mean I made a meme Jack Oh such a
jerk so I can surf on turtle Christian
work
I can make soup from turtle go that way
go go come on
epic I remembered it used to be a glitch
where you could like make them fly oh
yeah you would stand on top of it and
then try and hold it or something like
that yeah hello let's go to the tree
okay okay okay I'm by the tree of life
I'm seeing suitcases I'm running do you
see that ah oh it's pretty cool right
yeah well we should make a raft maybe oh
hey nice to meet you see you go brothers
we're looking for axes what's his name I
used to seek oh okay wait wait let me do
it I got a rock yeah yes come come no
you get along wait there is no kiss no
kiss wait slowly
[Music]
but I don't know if I'm ready Patricia
please you don't understand
I swear it was like one time magenta
okay I kiss back of his you ready moon
every time two grown-ass men
we're basically playing with dolls at
this point we might as well yeah okay
I'm going back to this other place to
the beach to find her I can no I'm
actually coming okay okay ready yeah
here okay okay one more time I'm ready
[Music]
Wow
that's right okay okay oh Jesus it's
[Music]
glued to my hair now don't go to the
boat please please okay okay oh god this
is horrible this is so scary
[Music]
there's a bed and also maybe rope that
we missed yes baby
check oh my name is jack let me get
there okay so rope to rope a rock and a
stick yes gamer yeah why are we freezing
home or indoors look it's fine I know I
know freeze I got this if you set
yourself on fire that's great Felix
Felix yes a long time ago there lived a
man all alone oh Jesus don't you hate it
when you're just hanging around waiting
for your bed to be ready being hard
Oh frickin sleeps time to make a big
camp we have access now it's time to
chop down trees okay that's a good point
you may actually with the bear argument
before this episode ends oh dear a
timber
and then our nice collector good we are
epic gamers build and all the log cabins
in game epic game we don't build it too
far away I'm playing at the beach all
right but then yes we carry from the
back all right sure the themes tactics
proud but your feet forever moist yeah
[Music]
it's funnier if I'm not there and I just
hear you I'm gonna put down a log-cabin
thing are you ready don't do too crazy
how many didn't need all right I guess
for building that yet
we need 82 what did I say let's say I
want an epic house okay so how many more
just 80 just 80 more Jack's fine just 80
this is just a team or Jack don't worry
about it it's okay yeah I guess so
so how do you make water I don't know
but I made a ball I shopped it whoa oh
my god that is my god right here oh my
god oh she's a chronic jerk oh hey Jack
I am Sharkey now surprises me oh wait I
got it hey so bad wait beep-beep-beep
I can hear ocean in here Wow wait look
it's like nothing happened
oh I haven't even how do you I left then
just fix things that's my boy so strong
right 65 gamer you really wanna know the
food turned into bones
goddamnit what did you do did you hit it
with your axe yeah go out into that
ocean I'll build you a wrap you can
never come back what it happened to all
of them then I hate barely touched it
we were so close okay perfect here we go
it's gonna happen take two cv cv cv oh
hey you like it yeah come on in
just walk in the door oh my god that's
awesome Hey Hey we killed some sharks we
saw some stuff and we didn't kill each
other that much I see this as an
absolute absolute win well you haven't
tried to be simulated citizen e after 50
million our troops by H don't just go
it's still relevant just download it